pourquoi dites-vous ja que c'est
vraiment cette petite izia le plus beau
cadeau que l'on vous ait fait puisque
vous avez trois enfants haïtiens il ya
cannes et arthur aussi voilà deux ou
trois matches les enfants en général
parce que mais sa set mais elle c'est
une future femme
et ça ça doit être important pour vous
oui c'est important très important
j'avais pas à quel point
parce que on apprend tout d'un coup en
tant qu'homme d'où ça vient et où elle
départ ça c'est une chose que je ne
voyais pas tout le temps comment jour
après jour et instant après instant
période après période se développait
tous les rapports entre un homme et une
femme
c'est vraiment très très important ça
c'est l'apprentissage du père par sa
fille c'est vrai c'est vraiment ça parce
qu'on s'élève avec son enfant on l'élève
leur intense élèves avec lui il vous
apprend plein de choses pour une année
de plus deux petits avant les deux qui
sont devenus grands et je me rappelle
toujours content quand il était petit et
vous remontre tout ce que vous aviez
déjà cru voir et vous remontre tout en
disant que ça et ça et ça a dit ça et ça
et des petites choses ces petites choses
qu'on finit par oublier on passe on dira
j'ai des problèmes je vais vraiment
angoissé tout ça et l'autre et dita qui
s'était sitruk tard car papa et tu
regardes et tu qu'est ce que c'est que
cette [ __ ] de fourmies qu'est ce qui
se passe un an
qu'est-ce-qui trafic et un moment donné
tu te retrouves à quatre pattes en train
de regarder ça et tu dis c'est
passionnant l'existence et à ce moment
là il ya un mec forcément qui frappe à
la porte et qui dit on vient chercher
tous les meubles tout ça
ici et il envoie chiffre est d'accord
avec l'idée que les enfants élèves
autant les parents que les parents
élèvent les enfants oui oui je fais sur
deux ça ça certains ma main au feu sur
la tête de ma fille et de mes fils et
puis je trouve que en fait quand on a
des enfants on arrête on n'arrête pas
les suivre
je sais pas j'ai toujours ce sentiment
d'être derrière les regarder et puis qui
m'entrainait vert vers l'avenir vers le
futur du monde et que moi à partir du
moment où il était venu au monde
j'avais à les suivre et à les aider pour
que découvre toutes les choses
[Musique]